I've got an email just yesterday from a
guy called Ryan Silvey who said this hey
Charlie sorry to bother you but are you
really Morgan Sylas cousin surprised
face if so I sit right in front of her
in Chinese class ha ha ha ha
dude that's crazy Ryan Stalvey sorry to
burst your bubble mr. Ryan but
unfortunately I don't know who this
Morgan character is it seems like she's
lying to you to try and gain some sort
of popularity which I do not endorse
it's also possible that she's lying to
try and impress you because she thinks
you're hot I don't know what the
circumstances are but the fact of the
bear is I'm not her cousin she's not my
cousin can we get on with the video now
all right thanks the first best friend
that I ever had was a fat kid called
Thomas Jenkins and the reason he was my
best friend was literally because he was
the only friend that I had and as I say
he was fat which did bother me at all
because you know he was my best friend
and I was just happy enough to have a
best friend but when you're in school
and the only friend that you have is the
tubby kids
you're not exactly gonna be high up in
terms of you know popularity or whatever
though I was only four years old so it's
possible I didn't really care too much
about popularity of that stage in my
life I remember this one specific
conversation that we had together while
we were in the playground and basically
he said Charlie can you go play with
somebody else but I don't have anyone
else to play with
what would why where do I go Charlie I
want you go play on somebody else why
don't you go play with somebody else
well yeah I knew the only person I know
how do i how do I make how what how do I
play with other people watch Charlie
play the suriya's go away and thus our
relationship as friends was no more I
got my second best friend pretty much by
default because I needed to someone to
go off to school on Wednesdays and it
seemed like max crichton's house was the
best place for me to go so that's where
I went as far as I was concerned he was
my best friend because I wanted him to
be my best friend because he was cool
cooler than me at least I don't know if
he thought the same way about me but as
far as I was concerned he was my best
friend they already made that clear well
that was a lot of light and I remember
thinking at the time that whatever we
did together just didn't didn't matter
because we were completely comfortable
as friends and that nothing could
tarnish our friendship and it was it was
very stupid of me to think that and I'll
tell you why me and my fellow classmates
I think I was about
9:00 at this point in my life and we
were having the in their inevitable
discussion about gay people basically
everybody in the playground for the gay
people were weird because that's kind of
what you think is a little kid you know
our men and women get married gay means
bad so gay people are strange but
there's some reason I wanted to show
that being gay wasn't weird I didn't
know what gay men I for the dis kissing
boys was was gay I wasn't attracted to
max but I kissed him and everybody
thought I was weird after that point and
we weren't friends anymore
yeah and so as time went on and I I lost
best friends and gain new ones and then
lost them again I came to the conclusion
in my mind the best friends weren't for
me I decided that I would be everyone's
friend but nobody's best friend and
that's how it was for pretty much the
entirety of secondary school I was I was
just kind of this guy that everyone knew
he was quite cool but not very and that
was that was me I was that was that was
it and then I found on YouTube I didn't
just make this video just to tell you
that I kissed a boy when I was nine by
the way even though I'm not gay
although that was part of it obviously
I'm making this because I'm interested
in what how people feel about best
friends and like what what affects best
friends have had on you if you've
managed to keep like a best friend for
your entire life so far and stuff like
that um I'm just I'm just curious
so yeah comments video responses are
welcome if you got anything to say thank
you and I'm also making this because I
always believe the best friends were was
a kiddy thing like my best friend but
I'm 18 at the moment and I didn't think
I would have a best friend at this point
in my life but I do and it's nice I
thought the videos was gonna end there
oh we're fading to black okay no worries
bye